Host: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to a very exciting
Musicians@Google event,
and before I’m actually gonna say more,
I wanna show you this.
♪ [music playing]
[applause]
Hi. I hope I’m gonna make it brief.
I was thinking about soundtracks.
The bad soundtrack can make a movie much,
much worse. Mediocre soundtrack—
you know it’s just gonna be there in
the background.
A good soundtrack is gonna
make a movie a little bit better.
A great soundtrack is gonna define
the movie.
An amazing soundtrack is gonna
define the genre.
If you really, really like it,
if you have a really, really
incredible soundtrack
it’s gonna make you wish your life
is a soundtrack of its own.
Now when you think about Bear’s Battlestar
Galactica soundtrack it’s really
in a league of its own
because, all of the these things aside,
it actually became a part of the series,
just integral part of what
Battlestar Gallactica was about.
And it shattered a couple of fourth walls
in the process
and I’m sure there were many more people
than me that it left speechless.
And if you look at
other projects by Bear McCreary
you know he did the TV show Trauma
and he incorporated actual helicopters
and ambulances in the soundtrack.
For Human Target, which is another show
Bear’s scoring right now
he routinely goes out and, and has
50–, 60–people orchestra
which is unprecedented for modern TV.
And the whole story of videogame
Dark Void which is a, Bear just went
and did the 8-bit version of the tune
and it kind of started a videogame
of its own.
Maybe he’ll talk about it a little bit more.
Bear composes, but he also plays piano,
he plays accordion,
he actually writes lyrics in all
sorts of different languages,
and I think I even saw him sing once or twice.
But whatever he does he approaches with so much
enthusiasm and passion
that I think we are all very lucky
to have him here,
talk about what he does;
and maybe play something
if we can convince him to.
And this is where my original introduction ends,
but we’re actually really, really lucky
because we also have Raya Yarbrough,
I don’t know where she is there,
who’s an incredibly talented vocalist.
And you think you don’t know her,
but if we can convince her to sing with Bear
you will kind of quickly realize where
do you know that gorgeous voice from.
So that’s the end of my thing here.
Please give it up for
Bear McCreary and Raya Yarbrough.
[applause]
Bear McCreary: Thank you, thank you.
That was a pretty cool introduction.
I don’t know how to follow that exactly.
This is Raya Yarbrough.
[applause]
So what we’re gonna,
before we do anything else-
Raya Yarbrough: Wanna, like, get you started.
Bear: Yeah. You were,
you were gonna ask me some things.
Raya: Okay.
There’s a lot stuff that Bear did before
Battlestar Galactica, so—
Why don’t we begin at the beginning.
Bear: Grab the mike.
Raya: Is this on?
Oh, it did it by itself.
It’s the magic of Google.
Okay, so I guess I’ll just,
oh, you’re miked, so you’re all good.
So why don’t you tell the good
people how you started off in music,
when you started, how.
Bear: Well,
you were,
you were clever enough to include
the Megaman clip in there.
Actually, 8-bit videogames were part of
the first musical experience I ever had.
And the combination of videogames
and movies and TV that I grew up on,
is what inspired me to become a musician.
And as I was growing up, I listened
to nothing but movie music.
It’s all I ever wanted to do and really
I never considered for a moment
that I would do anything else.
So I’m really lucky that it kind of worked
out because I didn’t have a backup plan.
And so I started—
I started writing my own music
when I was about, I don’t know, maybe ten;
and I sucked; I was not working.
But I just kept trying and I kept trying
and I kept listening to the pieces of music
that I was really responding to,
and, I don’t know, somewhere
in high school I started—
I started to kind of figure
a few things out.
And I started scoring little movies that
I was making and my friends were making
and trying to see if I could connect
music that I heard in my head
with the pictures that I was,
the pictures that I was dealing with,
and the images that I was dealing with.
And the answer was – no, I couldn’t,
at first.
But then I did it again and
I kept working at it,
and finally started to kind of find some,
I don’t know, I don’t wanna say
my own kind of inner voice,
but I did find some things that I
was able to do and gravitate towards.
And then I,
so then I ended up the
USC Thornton School of Music
where I actually learned how to
do music on a more formal level.
I didn’t have a lot of training up
until that point except for—
I studied classical piano for many years.
But that was sort of my musical
education was formalized there,
but it really started
by watching a bunch of movies
and playing videogames
more than anything else.
Raya: Yeah. I think,
and if I can weigh in here just
’cause I’ve happen to know you sort of well,
as your music has developed through all the
films and TV shows and things you’ve done,
you’ve, I’ve heard you saying
that you reflected back
to music that your wrote when you were 15 or 16,
and you realized, “you know, I kind
of did have a voice, even then.”
Bear: Yeah. That’s funny
I can find pieces when,
that I wrote in high school
and there’s a piece actually,
when I wrote the big theme for Dark Void
I played it for a buddy of mine and he’s
like, “You wrote that in high school.”
I’m like, “What are you talkin’ about?”
And he goes, “You know that one thing?”
and I went back and thought about it
and I went back to actually go and listen to it
and was like, “Oh, yeah.”
I mean it’s not as good,
but there was like all these little,
these little things that I was kind
of stumbling upon in high school
and then when I got this Dark Void
videogame I was able to kind of
draw on all these different influences.
And there’s pieces I wrote that
sound kind of like Battlestar, I mean,
other things that I’ve done.
Raya: And listening to your older
music and to music that you’re doing
like right now, it’s funny,
it’s almost like from your high school time
it was the seed and it grew into
this forest
which was Battlestar Galactica and everything.
And now it’s almost like you’re kind of
harkening back to some of your original–
could you talk about some of
your original inspirations,
some of the people who influenced you
from way, way back–
Bear: The first film score
that I noticed was
Back To The Future by Alan Silvestri.
Anybody remember that score?
Yeah.
Raya: Somebody saying—
Bear: That one.
No, it’s weird.
I talk to people and they are like,
they’ve never even heard of the movie sometimes.
It’s just one of those franchises.
[laughter]
I know. That’s when I was like,
“I feel old.”
You can talk to a perfectly formed
human being who was born
after Back To The Future 3 came out.
So, yeah, it’s weird.
That was one of the first ones
that caught my ear.
And, simultaneously, it was the same year,
Pee-wee’s Big Adventure by Danny Elfman
really struck a chord with me
and that was – starting after that
point my parents would notice that
any time that I went and saw a movie,
I would identify the composer within the
first five or ten seconds of the movie.
And I was six, seven, eight years old.
And then the credits would come up
and they’re like, “God damn, he’s right.”
And so they kind of knew, they could
kind of see where I was going.
Then in, I also, as a kid, really loved
the music of John Williams.
Temple Of Doom and Empire Strikes Back
had a big impression on me for sure.
And then it was in
high school that I discovered–
I had this sort of epiphany
when I discovered the film music of
Jerry Goldsmith, Elmer Bernstein,
Bernard Herrmann, Nino Rota and Ennio Morricone.
I think of these five guys as the people that I,
I’m influenced by the most,
and the reason I say that is
that I realize that everybody that
I adored was borrowing from them.
And I would go and discover
these scores from the 50s
that sounded like the scores
from the late 80s and 90s
that I was falling in love with.
Not in a bad way, I mean,
just the influence was there
and that they were innovating,
I mean stuff like Herrmann’s
The Day The Earth Stood Still
or Elmer Bernstein’s
To Kill A Mockingbird,
which if you put that
in a movie trailer today,
I don’t think anyone would think
that that music was 55 years old.
So it’s, that was
a big sort of epiphany for me
when I realized how far back
this tradition goes
and started studying very closely
what those guys were doing.
Raya: Can you say
a little about Elmer?
Bear: I can.
I knew Elmer,
I met him when I was in high school and—
Raya: It’s Elmer Bernstein.
Bear: Yeah.
Elmer Bernstein who, who did so many
of the most important film scores
to ever be written;
The Ten Commandments,
The Great Escape,
To Kill A Mockingbird,
The Magnificent Seven,
Animal House,
Ghost Busters,
the list goes on and on.
I met him when I was in high school
and I played him a bunch of my music
’cause we had a mutual friend through
this weirdest coincidence in the world.
And he was really impressed with,
I think the energy that I had,
and the amount of stuff I was writing
and he asked if I was formally trained,
although I’m sure in hindsight
he knew that I wasn’t.
And he really kind of took me
under his wing.
And when I came down to
Los Angeles to go to school,
I started working for him and one of the,
no, I guess the first professional
job I ever had was at his,
at his, at his house,
his estate.
And he was gone for the summer and he goes,
“Hey, like, can you housesit
the place
and then I’ll give
you a film to orchestrate over the summer.”
And I was like—
[laughter]
“Yeah, let me check my schedule.” You know.
So actually a quick side story.
I was, I had to,
I had to dog sit—
he had these dogs—
and you had to give them these pills
and stuff, and I’m like, “Alright, sure.”
I did not tell him that since I was
a kid I had this phobia of dogs,
’cause when I was a little
kid I got attacked by a dog.
And I was like, “Alright, I just,
I just gotta get over this.
How big can this dog be?”
Irish Wolfhound. Okay. [laughter]
It is this big,
I mean on all fours.
It comes up to here on me.
And in fact,
when it was a puppy they,
they had to put it on downers
because it would jump up on Elmer
and it’s like eight feet high.
So I get over there and I
see this dog and it was like,
“Okay. Let’s…”
My dog, my fear of dogs is of course
non-existent anymore after that summer.
Anyway, so that was a huge influence
on me because I spent the whole summer
re-orchestrating a film score
called Kings Of The Sun.
This was a movie starring Yul
Brynner that came out in 1968.
I think it’s on DVD,
no, it is on DVD now.
At the time it wasn’t on DVD,
it wasn’t on TV,
it wasn’t screened anywhere,
it had had a theatrical run
and that was it.
And it was still one of the most highly
sought-after scores that Elmer had written.
Fans were writing him and saying,
“Oh, when are you gonna perform
that music?
Is it gonna be on a soundtrack album?”
And the recordings had been destroyed,
the scores had been destroyed,
because at that point in time
the studio would keep everything.
And in fact he would tell me stories of
sometimes he’d go to music departments
to meet a director and he would look at
someone’s writing on a scrap of paper like,
just notes, they have a stack of old
scrap paper and you’d flip it over
and it’s a handwritten Jerry Goldsmith
score from like the late 70s.
It was “Oh, there it is.”
But anyway, so who knows where his
score is now somebody’s laundry list or,
or grocery list or something.
So I re-orchestrated this whole film.
So I spent the summer,
he had his handwritten sketches
were literally all that remained—
and so I was able to go through
and recreate the orchestration
and I didn’t have a recording
or anything to go by.
And that taught me more than any program, any class,
any teacher could have ever taught me,
because I was just was able to see
exactly how the germs of the ideas
became this finished score.
And in fact,
one of the other things that
I did for him was,
was, I sort of organized his
whole closet full of archives
which is now in a collection
at the USC Music Library.
But at the time it was just
a closet full of stuff,
and I was going through it with him
and there were all these things
that he didn’t wanna keep.
He was just gonna, he’s like,
“No. Throw all that stuff out.”
And I said, “I can’t,
I don’t know why, but I can’t
throw this out.”
It’s like a stack of parts
from the day they recorded
the cues on To Kill A Mockingbird.
He was gonna throw them out.
These are the actual parts
that the musicians read from.
They’re in my closet now and
I don’t know what to do with them,
but I was like
“Do you mind if I keep these?”
And one of the things that he was
gonna throw out that’s on my wall
that I look at every day
is a handwritten sketch
of the main title in The Great Escape.
And you can see how he thought
of it and before he wrote this,
that melody didn’t exist.
I mean like,
I’ll play it real quick.
I mean this kind of blows,
blows my mind, right?
That he wrote this—
♪ [playing upbeat piano]
I mean, everybody knows this tune, right?
I mean you think it’s like
an old American folk tune.
But he wrote it.
And, I just thought before this piece of
paper existed that song did not exist.
And when he was gonna throw
that out I was just like,
“No, no way, can I, I gotta,
I gotta keep this.”
And so he had a great impact
on me creatively,
professionally,
but also personally because I,
I got to spend so much time with him
and, see that it is possible to
be successful in the movie business
and the music business, and not
turn out to be a big asshole.
[laughter] So that was, that
was an eye opener for sure.
Raya: So in the steps
of not becoming a big asshole,
shortly after that—
Bear: Oh, I am a big asshole.
I failed at that. [laughter]
Raya: Well, but you grew into it.
Bear: Yeah, so—
Raya: Of course the four
seasons of Battlestar Gallactica.
Bear: Yes.
Raya: So, so let’s,
let’s talk about this.
Bear: Um…
Raya: How did you,
how did you get into Battlestar
and, yeah.
Bear: Battlestar
was my first job out of school.
I, I got it,
the first job that I got,
I was,
I graduated,
I had nothing going on,
I was actually even,
I crashed at Elmer’s place, at his
Santa Monica house, for a month.
So I could score a student film
with a budget of zero dollars.
But I said, it was like,
“I gotta finish this movie.”
So I was like literally about to go
hand in applications at grocery stores
and video stores—
Raya: There was florist store—
Bear: Florist. Yeah, florist,
I could have done that.
Raya: He makes
brilliant flower arrangements.
Bear: I could have been a florist.
Raya: If you like his music,
you should see…
Bear: Yeah.
Raya: …his flower arrangements.
[laughter]
Bear: But I got a job
working for Richard Gibbs.
Richard Gibbs is a film composer
and former keyboardist
of Oingo Boingo
which is another story for later on, I guess.
And, so I got a job working for him
and I was his assistant.
I kept the studio running.
I converted all his computers
to the new sampling software
which has since become a dinosaur
and I’m the only one who uses it now.
But at the time, it was new.
And I also wrote a bunch of cues
and worked with the producers
and helped him meet his deadlines.
And he,
so I worked there about a year,
and at the end of that year
he landed the Battlestar Galactica mini-series.
So he asked me to come on board
and help him finish this pilot,
it was essentially a backdoor pilot.
And we had to write three,
almost three hours of music, maybe two and
a half hours of music, in about 14 days.
So it was an incredible turnaround
and on top of that,
the producer had this really
wacky idea of using taiko drums
and that was kind of all that he said.
He was like, “We like taiko drums.”
[laughter]
And I was like, “Okay. I don’t know
what that means.”
And so actually in that creative process,
I worked very closely with Richard
and also with,
with the director Michael Rymer,
and so when we got through the mini-series,
and we did use a hefty amount
of taiko drums.
But also a lot of,
there was a lot of orchestral writing and,
and a very sort of ambient non-thematic approach.
And this was because the producers
felt very strongly
that they didn’t want the kind of Star Wars
or Star Trek approach to their mini-series.
In fact,
if you think about it in comparing the new,
the mini-series to the old show,
the thing that is the most
different is the music.
I think more than anything else.
it’s the one part of the old
show that was completely,
well, except for the Casino Planet,
that was dropped too. [laughter]
Alright. So there were two things:
the music and the Casino Planet.
Raya: Boxey,
don’t forget about Boxey.
Bear: We had Boxey in the pilot.
Raya: You did?
Bear: We did.
And in season one they dropped him on his ass.
Raya: That’s right.
[laughs]
Bear: But yeah, he
was there briefly.
It was the dagget
that was also missing.
Alright, there
were a few things missing.
Raya: There was
a dagget at one point, remember?
Bear: Oh, yeah.
Raya: Yeah. I don’t know
what scene it is,
but if you look at one scene you can see
a dagget flying out of the airlock.
Bear: Yeah. It’s true.
There is a dagget and—
And, I think the Starship Enterprise
and the Millennium Falcon
are in the fleet in a couple of shots.
Raya: Oh, that’s right.
[laughter]
Bear: Yeah. A bunch of nerds
worked on the show. [laughter]
So, but anyway, so long,
long story medium-long,
the pilot is relatively
successful and it goes to series.
And at that point Richard needs
to go on to feature films.
He’s got his slate is full with feature
films and he can’t take on a weekly series
that would require the amount of
original music that Battlestar required.
So, of course, the producers
didn’t wanna hire me at all.
And while they were off
looking for other people,
there was one deadline coming up
which was for this episode “33,”
which was the first episode aired.
So they go, “Alright, well, you can take,
you can do this while we’re
off looking for somebody else.”
And so I did it.
I did the hell out of it and
really gave it my all and,
and brought in all the musicians
that I wanted to bring in.
All of whom stayed on ’til the end.
That episode planted the seeds
thematically that would go all the way
to the last episode.
But I didn’t know any better
at the time.
I mean, I was just,
I was just trying to,
I don’t even wanna say I
was trying to keep the job,
I was just trying to do an excellent job
because I really adored that episode.
I mean I thought it was
so gripping and powerful
and a worthy follow-up
of the mini-series.
And after the playback the producers
invited me to come look at the next episode.
And I thought, “Okay. We’re doing
two episodes of Battlestar.”
So that feeling of waiting for,
I can get fired tomorrow, though,
that went away about halfway
through season four. [laughter]
That’s when I started,
when I was like,
“You know, I probably am gonna finish this show.
I think, I think I’m gonna stick around.”
But that’s it.
I was,
I had just turned 24 when I became
the composer of Battlestar Galactica
and it was, it was really through—
Raya: How did you feel starting
your career so late? [laughter]
Bear: Yeah, I know.
I know. [laughter]
It was tough.
Well, seriously when I was 15, I was like,
“I’m gonna be famous by the time I’m 20.
I’ll just land a big movie.”
The funny thing is when I was,
when I was a kid I never wanted to do TV.
I wanted to do movies.
And ironically the creative freedom
that I have found in television,
and I find that the quality
in television
surpasses most of what comes out
in theaters,
and I think about all the big summer action
blockbusters that come out and I go,
“Well, this would be cool if I did that,”
but would I have traded four years
of Battlestar, you know?
Raya: Actually that,
that leads me, blah, blah,
that leads me to a question.
You were talking about the,
in television you really have time
to develop the sound of a show.
Can you talk a little bit about
how the Battlestar music developed?
Bear: Yeah.
Raya: From your beginnings in
season one to the stuff in season four.
Bear: Well, like I said—
Raya: There’s some
really unique narrative stuff.
Bear: Yeah. The show,
the music went through a lot of changes,
which is something that I think
is unusual for television or,
or it’s unusual for what people think
of as typical television scoring.
The idea, I think, of TV scoring is that
I think of the pinnacle and also
the pinnacle of functional TV music
was something like Seinfeld, right,
where you can hear that slap bass sound,
yeah you, can you give us an example?
Raya: [making sounds]
Bear: There you go. [laughter]
Alright. And you know exactly
what show you’re watching,
there’s no question,
it’s doing exactly what it needs to
do to get us from point B to point C.
With Battlestar it needed a much
more cinematic and dramatic approach,
but they also didn’t want what they felt
was a cinematic typical sci-fi opera score.
So they said,
they said, “no themes” in the beginning.
So I go, “Okay. No themes.”
And yet in the first episode that I did,
I wrote this little thing when,
when Boomer and Helo are down on
the planet I had this little thing,
I remember it—
♪ [playing pensive piano]
I’m not gonna win any awards for that,
but it’s a little germ of an idea that
I used whenever Helo and Boomer were on,
were on Caprica.
And then in the second episode
we went back to Caprica
to follow that story line more and I thought,
“Well, why should I write
a new little melody,
I’ll just use that one.”
But that’s a theme now.
[laughter]
And especially at this point when
I’m fearing for my job, I thought,
“If I tell them I’m doing this,
then I’m gonna get fired.”
So I didn’t tell them and used that again.
And then there was a little,
there was a, in episode
four of season one
I should stay at the piano –
there was a theme for Kara—
♪ [playing piano]
And that came back in episode,
it was in episode four and then
it came back in episode five
and then the next couple
of scenes with Kara,
I had a chance to use it again
and it was clearly a theme,
but I was just,
I was afraid to tell anybody.
[laughter]
And then in episode eight,
so in episode eight, which
is “Flesh and bone,”
that episode to me is a pivotal one
because it begins what became a,
a unique trait to Battlestar
which is our characters,
all of our characters become
repulsive in one way or another.
All of our characters do something
that makes us question whether they’re,
they’re doing the right thing or not.
And in this particular episode Kara Thrace
starts torturing Leoben,
and of course this also sets in motion
the end of her whole story line
and her relationship with Leoben
and all these things.
But I don’t think, I’m not sure
the writers knew all of that ahead.
They certainly didn’t tell me if they did.
But in that episode I thought, “Well,
if this is the triumphant Kara—
♪ [playing piano]
then Film Score 101 says,
says to just make it minor—
♪ [playing piano]
and then you have moody, dark—
conflicted Kara.
[laughter]
But then the producers might feel
it’s a theme. And— [laughter]
I would get fired.
[laughter]
So I did it anyway,
and I didn’t get fired.
And so by about the,
so now at the end of season one in episode
ten which is called “The hand of God”,
I was spotting with,
with one of the producers
and there is a scene there where
Helo and Boomer are hiding out—
there is this whole story line
throughout that season—
and every episode I’m playing
a little Boomer theme.
And the producers look at
that scene and he’s like,
“You know having trouble,
this one’s not quite working,
something’s not connecting,
can we, can we use that
Boomer theme that you wrote.
Can we use a little Boomer theme there?”
I was like, [laughter]
“Um, good idea boss.
Yeah. Boomer theme.”
And at that point I thought, “Okay.”
But it was a, that was a big sort
of moment for me when I realized,
“Okay. They get it that themes can be subtle.
Themes can be a color.
Themes can be a couple of notes.”
I think that to a sci-fi audience,
well, pre-Battlestar perhaps,
the word theme means Luke staring off
into the twin sunsets
and the french horn is playing “THE THEME”
and anything less than that,
and I love that stuff,
but it would have sunk Battlestar.
That kind of approach in early Battlestar
would have, would have been,
I think just, I don’t know.
It wouldn’t have been,
it wouldn’t have been right.
But I had a highly thematic approach.
I was doing the same thing
that Williams was doing,
I was just doing it with
different musical tools.
As that, once I knew that was okay,
which was episode ten of season one,
and you can,
you can tell in the scores the point at
which the producer used the word theme
and I realize I wasn’t gonna get fired.
So starting with episode ten things start to blossom.
And I introduced—
Raya: In what ways did
you expand your musical palette,
like instrument wise.
Bear: Well, I was
going to get to that.
In episode ten there was a,
there was a, a Gaelic element that
I introduced with this theme—
♪ [playing very melodic piano]
So in the texture of Battlestar
this did not fit at all.
And I knew that it didn’t fit,
but there was this one scene that it did fit.
At the end of this episode there
was this big jubilant celebration
which itself didn’t fit the tone
of the show at that point.
But one of the things
I was realizing is that
this show was expanding and developing
and changing.
So once that was, that scene
was in there, I thought,
“Well, maybe I can use that as
a theme earlier in the episode
in a more emotional setting.”
So I did and I didn’t get fired.
So that became a theme for,
for Lee and his father and then that
started coming back in season two.
That start set me on this path
where now the score was beginning
to expand instrumentally.
And what used to be just taiko drums
and an occasional Middle Eastern woodwind
and an electric fiddle,
now included bagpipes.
Raya: Don’t forget
the wailing chick.
Bear: And the wailing chick.
[laughter]
And…
[laughter] [applause]
Yes. Yes.
And then, so then in,
in the end of season one
we added the orchestra back in
which is the thing that the producers said
adamantly that they wanted no orchestra.
Well, they changed their mind.
And the orchestra again,
it wasn’t Luke staring off
into twin sunsets,
it was, it could be used in,
in more tasteful ways for Battlestar,
not dogging on Williams.
I love that stuff.
But when the season ended,
the score had changed dramatically.
And so then in season two,
it began to change right from the get go
and we started adding in some
Indian sitar and some tabla.
And then in the middle of season two,
about another ten episodes in,
we added a rock band,
with this episode called “Pegasus.”
And then the orchestral
music became more pronounced.
And so now there
was a pop-rock element.
We went into season three and
I changed up the taiko writing.
I added a lot more authentic
Japanese percussion.
Between season two and three,
I did a lot of research into how
Japanese music uses taiko drums
and that, on the soundtrack album there’s
this track called “Storming New Caprica”
which sounds different.
I mean you can just tell it sounds
different than season one and two.
And the bagpipes are still being
used in these episodes
and you get to season three,
the end of season three,
with “All along the watchtower” which was
a weird enough inclusion- on its own-
Raya: But you want to tell
them how that came to be at all or—
kind of a little synopsis.
Bear: Well, the interesting
thing is all of these things,
I wanna stress I’m not just throwing
these in because I got bored.
Quite the contrary.
Most of the time, as a composer
if you were working on a show
that is in one language and
you just come in and you’re like,
“Hey, I wanna do some bagpipes in
this episode,” you’re gonna get fired.
It was something that
the producers encouraged
and in many ways forced me to do.
Because the writing evolved,
the acting evolved,
the characters changed so much;
Kara Thrace is a perfect example.
Her opening theme which I played you,
was rather warm and triumphant and
then I created a dark version of it.
Well, in season three we learned
all about this special destiny
that she might have, so I wrote
a theme for that.
And then later in season three
we learned about this relationship
that she has with Lee and that
got expanded on dramatically.
None of these other themes would
work and I wrote a theme for that.
And Baltar was another character
that had multiple themes
for their different personalities and
one of the things that I realized is that
these people are not archetypes.
You can’t write one theme that
encapsulates everything about them.
And if you think about
your own personality,
as much as we’d like to think,
“Well, if I’m the hero of my movie,
I’d have the hero theme.”
Well, there’s days when your cranky
and you have to have a cranky theme.
I mean people are complicated,
multi-faceted individuals
and Battlestar is a perfect
example of every character being like this.
So I was forced to expand
greatly as this show went on.
And “Watchtower” came along—
this was an idea that Ron Moore
had in season one.
He wanted the ending of season one
to be Baltar in his dream
walking into the symphony hall and there’s
somebody playing “All along the watchtower”
and the writer’s like,
“Dude, no way.” [laughter]
So, and then in season two we wanted to
bring it back and the writers were like,
“No way.”
In season three finally I think he came
up with the reason to use it.
And they go, “Well, okay.”
And—
Raya: What, what was
your first response when you—
Bear: I thought he was nuts.
I thought it was—
[laughter]
I thought it was the end of the show.
Honestly, I thought it
was the end of the show.
Because I didn’t know
how it was gonna be used.
I didn’t see the episode, I
also hadn’t read the script.
All I got a phone call was producer going,
“Dude, Ron wants you to do an
All Along The Watchtower.”
I was just like, “Good-bye.”
[laughter]
But the more I thought about it,
I thought,
“Well, there might be some potential here.”
Raya: There might
be some way… out of here?
Bear: Yes. [laughter]
That was the second thing I thought.
[laughter]
Well, you know, I had an idea and I thought,
“Well, I’ll try this.”
I had an idea to do—
we had introduced taiko drums,
we’d introduced Middle Eastern music,
we’d introduced African music,
heavy metal had snuck into the score in an
episode called “Black market,”
which was just this source piece that I’d
done because I wanted to a heavy metal song
but there it was, on the
season two soundtrack,
and it was in the fabric of the show.
So I thought, “Well, I’ll try
to do the version of this,
of Watchtower that I think would be cool.
And then I can at least tell everybody that
there was a cool version at one point
in the past.”
’Cause I was sure that this wouldn’t fly.
So I did this, what I called,
George Harrison sits in with
Rage Against The Machine,
kind of Indian, Middle Eastern version
of “All along the watchtower.”
So I threw it together – a demo.
My brother stepped off a plane
and he recorded the demo vocals
and I sent it to Ron
and I was just like,
“Okay. Well, that will be the end of this.”
And Ron writes back and he’s like,
“Oh, it’s great.” [laughter]
And it was, that was it.
“No, I can totally see that fitting
with the action in the episode.”
And I was like, “There’s
action in the episode?”
I didn’t even know.
And ultimately the version that
you hear on the album
and in the show is almost identical;
some of the tracks are from the demo.
It’s exactly what my initial vision
was, and I think part of that is,
is thanks to Ron letting me do
whatever I wanted; he gave me no input.
I mean it was literally the first time
that the producer said nothing to me.
Before I wrote it, I caught him
in the hallway and I said,
“Ron, dude, what, what do you want me to do?
It is, should it sound like Bob Dylan?
Should it sound like Jimi Hendrix?”
And he goes,
“Make it sound like Battlestar.”
And he walked away.
[laughter]
Like this was easy,
you know? [laughter]
And I also think that
the network had faith in Ron.
I personally believe that they
weren’t sure what to make of it.
I think it was something
that was extremely daring,
I mean whether you liked it or not,
it was extremely daring.
And that blasted open the doors
in season four
where now the music is something
the characters hear;
the themes are melodies they’re aware of;
and the music became a part
of the show in a way that
I can’t think of another film or television
show that did it in this exact way.
And the writers began calling me.
I was on set.
I was involved in the scripts—
Raya: It got kind of
meta eventually,
because first it was kinda like you’re
following the narrative of the show—
And then, and what’s,
what’s the name of the episode—
Bear: Well, “Someone to watch
over me” was one of the first ones.
Raya: Yeah, suddenly
the show started following you.
Bear: Exactly.
The character in that named Slick,
who’s this piano player,
every time he’s talking about music,
what he’s saying is what I was saying
when I was writing
that season’s mid-season cliffhanger
in an episode called “Revelations.”
So you’ve got to think about this;
I’m writing, I’m struggling
to write this cue
that was one of the toughest cues
I’d ever written,
and the writers called me
up and they’re like,
“Can we take a minute of your time?
We got this character, a composer;
he’s writing a cue;
he’s having trouble with it.
What is that like?”
And I was just like— [laughter]
“Dammit.”
[laughter]
So like it was, it was perfect.
I mean literally David Weddle
was like,
“Hang on.
Don’t, don’t figure it out,
don’t figure it out,
let me get a pencil,
we’ll write this down.” [laughter]
So that’s exact,
it was me, that was me,
what I was going through to write this,
this other cue.
Raya: And in fact you got
so close that
you went up to the set for that one.
Bear: Yeah, I was,
I was on set
and I worked with the actors,
I worked with Katee and Roark,
I taught them the piano parts.
Roark is an excellent pianist
and as he was actually cast
so that he could play my music.
They only auditioned
people that could play piano.
And – fun trivia – they actually
auditioned me for this. [laughter]
Needless to say, my talents are
clearly on the compositional side.
[laughter]
But—
Raya: But you went to
the audition.
Bear: I did. I did.
It was, yeah.
[laughter]
So, and then even in the last episode,
I will keep this,
is there anyone here who hasn’t seen
the last episode? Raise your hand.
It’s okay. Okay.
I just, alright.
I won’t spoil it.
In the last episode,
something happens, yeah.
And there, there are—
And there are, there are,
there are coordinates involved.
And these are coordinates that,
that I came up with.
Actually Ron called me and was like,
“Hey, we need a way to,
to communicate this idea that the music
and the coordinates are tied together.”
And actually I worked with Kevin Grazier,
the science advisor, and I was like,
“Well, tell me how many coordinates,
how many digits do we need?”
And he would, he’s, you guys
probably know better than I do,
it was, he needed 12 digits
to create this set of coordinates.
And by coincidence the theme that
I was messing around with at the time
had 12 notes.
♪ [playing piano]
And then returning to one is 13.
♪ [plays one note on piano]
For the thirteenth colony. Ooh.
[laughter] Naah, I’m making that up.
Yeah, that was a coincidence.
But anyway, it was a happy coincidence
and then I thought, “okay”—
and I devised a number of different
ways we could generate these pitches
and I came up with complex grids of
intervals and different scaling,
ways of numbering a scale
to create these numbers.
And I said to the writers, “Okay, well
how long is the scene that we have to explain this.
I mean is it like, how many, how
many lines of dialog do we have
to like to sell this idea?”
Somebody’d be like, “Well, actually let’s
microanalyze the blah, blah, blah.”
And he’s like, “Oh,
there’s no dialog.”
And—
well, one little spoiler.
“They’re about to get sucked into the
black hole, everyone’s about to die,
and there’s no dialog, they
just have to kind of do it.
And you have, but you have to
sell that it comes from the music.”
And I was like, “Uh, okay.”
And then actually I worked
with the editor very closely
to create this idea that these
are numbers that come to Kara
and what I ended up doing
was numbering the scale,
just the very bottom note is one,
and then just going up the scale
not counting the chromatic notes,
so going up the scale one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
And then she just – fortunately they
were all, they’re all numbers under 10,
so they’re all single
digit numbers, so those,
the twelve digits that she plays in are
the twelve notes that of the theme.
And, I know, and then as the editor
cut it together we cut her punching
in the numbers on the keypad to
her playing the notes on the piano
and, I don’t know,
did that come across at all,
or were you guys like,
“what the hell just happened?”
Did that,
did you get it?
Alright.
So that was pretty extraordinary,
I mean that was sort of the
evolution of that score and it was,
it was a pretty extraordinary journey.
Raya: It’s pretty amazing
that way the show and the music
really did mesh entirely.
Bear: Yeah.
Raya: In the same thing.
Well, let’s see, there are two
directions we could go in right now.
We could play some music,
or we could play some video.
What would you like to do?
Bear: Music, huh?
Raya: Wanna make music?
Bear: Alright.
Raya: Alright.
Bear: Well, let’s play something then.
Raya: So what makes sense is
what you were talking about.
Bear: Well, you wanna do the
theme? “Apocalypse”?
Raya: Okay.
Should I say what it is?
Bear: ♪ [playing piano]
Yeah, if you want.
Raya: Okay.
Bear: Yeah, go for it.
Raya: Alright.
See if you remember this little diddy.
Welcome to the Battlestar Galactica lounge,
after hours. [laughter]
So glad you could join us.
Bear: Don’t forget
to tip your waitress.
Raya: Yeah, don’t
forget to tip your waitress.
♪ Oṃ bhūr bhuvaḥ svaḥ
♪ Tat savitur vareṇyaṃ
♪ Bhargo devasya dhīmahi
♪ dhiyo yo naḥ pracodayāt
♪ Oṃ bhūr bhuvaḥ svaḥ
♪ Tat savitur vareṇyaṃ
♪ Bhargo devasya dhīmahi
♪ dhiyo yo naḥ pracodayāt
[applause]
Bear: Cool. Do you wanna
do the other one?
Raya: Yeah.
Bear: Yeah?
Raya: Yeah. Let’s do that.
Bear: Alright.
Raya: So that was,
should I say what that was?
Does anybody know what that was?
You call yourselves Battlestar fans.
Thank you.
Yes, that was the opening theme.
Bear:  ♪ [playing piano] Yeah.
Raya: Otherwise known
as the Gayatri Mantra.
Otherwise known as “Apocalypse.”
Bear: Yeah, that theme
had a lot of different forms.
Raya: That theme has a lot of names.
A lot of different places.
Bear: ♪ [playing piano]
Raya: ♪ Dei Kobol
♪ una apita athoukarana
♪ Ukthea mavatha
♪ gaman kerimjuta
Raya: ♪ Dei Kobol
Bear: ♪ [dramatic piano]
♪ una apita athoukarana
♪ Ukthea mavatha
♪ gaman kerimjuta
♪ Dei Kobol
♪ una apita athoukarana
♪ Ukthea mavatha
♪ gaman kerimjuta
♪ Dei Kobol
Bear: ♪ [dramatic piano]
[laughter]
[applause]
Raya: Happy ending.
Bear: Yeah, I know.
Two downers in a row.
Raya: Should
we do a little pop quiz?
Bear: Yeah. It’s a good idea.
Raya: Just for those two songs?
Bear: You think?
Raya: Yeah. Should we do the
pop quiz we’ve been talking about?
Bear: Do we want, you want
to do, you want to try see if…
Raya: Yeah, let’s do the one
we’ve been talking about.
Bear: Yeah. Alright.
That’d be fun.
Raya: Do we have our questions?
Bear: Yeah.
Raya: We have a special event.
Even more special than
this overarching event.
Bear: Yeah.
Why don’t you ask the questions.
Raya: Okay.
Should I?
Bear: Here’s the question, though—
Raya: Okay.
Bear: Which—
we have four prizes,
and three of them are cool
and one’s not as cool.
Raya: Even cooler, oh.
Bear: Yes, even cooler.
Raya: Okay. So should
I ask these questions?
And should I say what the prize is
or should we…?
Bear: Yeah, why don’t
we give those three away first.
Raya: Okay.
Bear: And then the fourth person
gets stuck with the less cool one,
or more cool depending on how…
what they…
Raya: Okay, so whoever gets this
right will get those prizes…
Bear: No, this—
Raya: Talk amongst yourselves.
Bear: This one should be the
fourth, so they are in the right order.
Raya: Okay, okay, okay.
So whoever knows this,
just kind of jump up and
shout it. And then you’ll win.
Bear: And no googling the answers.
Raya: Yeah, seriously,
guys, come on.
Okay, so get ready.
Question number one.
What was Caprica Six’s first line ever?
Raya: There you go.
“Are you alive?”
Bear: Close.
So what is – what has she won?
I don’t even— [laughter]
Host: Is this on?
We do have all the Battlestar Galactica CDs,
including the new one that’s unavailable
anywhere else, even on iTunes.
The Caprica CD and the sheet
music for “Battlestar Sonatica.”
[applause]
Raya: Okay, now, question number
two is actually linked to what…
what we just did up here right now.
What language is the BSG main title sung in?
Bear: I heard one over here.
Close.
Raya: Good guess, but no cigar.
I heard it over there.
Yeah, you got it. [laughter]
Forgive me for pronouncing things wrong.
The answer was Sanskrit.
Bear: The answer is Sanskrit.
Although, who said Armenian?
There is a song in Armenian.
Raya: Yeah, that’s why
there was a – do you know which one?
Bear: But not the main title.
Raya: Supplemental question:
Lords of Kobol.
What language is that in?
Anyone know?
Bear: Close.
Raya: There is a
Gaelic song but that’s not it.
Raya: Greek?
There is something in Greek.
Bear: Caprica, all
the Caprica stuff is in Greek.
Raya: Caprica’s on Greek.
Raya: “Battlestar Operatica.”
Uh-huh, good.
The answer is Sinhalese.
Actually, didn’t expect anyone to get that.
Okay. Number three:
Name – sound good?
Bear: Yeah.
This, this might, we might—
I don’t know if anyone will get that.
Raya: Might stump someone.
Number three: Name a player
in Bear McCreary’s orchestra—
Bear: – who is not
one of us or my brother –
Raya: – who is
neither of us or Bear’s brother,
who played in,
on the show at some point.
Some musician.
Anyone?
Bear: Oh, stumped them.
Bear: Yeah, we would
have accepted Alessandro Juliani.
No, I’m kidding.
Raya: Well, that’s true,
actually.
Bear: Okay. I got another one.
I got another one.
Do we take partial credit
for a half answer?
Raya: That’s pretty
deep, actually, that you know that.
Bear: All right.
All right. I got another one.
What… Members of my orchestra are also
members of a famous cult band from the 80s.
I heard it.
Who said it?
There it is. Oingo Boingo.
But I think she said it first.
[applause]
Bear: There you go.
Raya: And this for
our final prize? This one here?
Bear: Yeah, our last kind
of not cool, but not horrible prize.
Raya: The might-be-interesting prize.
Bear: I want somebody
from the audience to come up
and I’m going to teach them how
to play the Katee Sackhoff’s part
from “All along the watchtower.”
So—
Raya: Best prize ever?!
Bear: the question—
Raya: Do you want to
say the question?
Bear: No, you can do it.
Raya: Do you want
me to say the question? Okay.
What was the name of the episode
where Bear had a cameo?
Where Bear was onscreen?
Anyone?
Some head scratching going on.
Member of the audience: “Making of.”
Bear: I think for partial
credit, since we did not say,
I’m not counting “the making of.”
I think we have a winner.
Raya: You think so?
Bear: Yeah.
Raya: All right.
Come on up. [laughter]
[applause]
Bear: What’s your name?
Member of the audience: Minh.
Bear: Hi, nice to meet you.
So have you ever played piano at all?
Minh: Yeah, but I’m very basic.
Bear: So, all right.
So your first note is here.
♪ [playing piano]
Bear: You got it.
♪ [piano playing continues]
[applause]
Bear: There you go. Awesome.
Yeah, great work.
Great work.
[applause]
Bear: Excellent.
Excellent.
Um, any questions?
We can do Q&A, I guess, if
there’s anything I didn’t cover.
All right, good night!
No, I’m kidding.
Just step up to the mike.
Member of the audience: I haven’t quite figured out
how to phrase this,
but you talked a lot about melodies and, you
know, notes and pitches during your stuff,
but I’m kind of curious to hear
more about rhythm.
Since you use a lot of rhythm in
your music of all different cultures
and particularly how that corresponds
to the pacing over the whole—
like an episode is a really long thing,
right? So—
Bear: Well, rhythm
is an important tool
when you’re not allowed to write melodies,
which is how I started.
I literally had nothing but rhythm.
So that was how I started the score
and I would think of themes
in terms of rhythmic ideas.
And I find that melodies are
probably more effective for use as themes
because it’s easier to have a melody
stuck in your head than a rhythm.
But in terms of pacing across
a whole episode—
I always think about the bigger picture
when I—
when I compose.
And, generally, what I do is
I look at an episode
and I start with the biggest part of it—
what I know is the most intense cue
and I—
not only because it’s the most difficult
and then it feels really good
when you’re done with it,
but that way I also know that
everything that I write needs
to lead up to that
and it’s generally toward
the end of the episode.
Sometimes like in the case
of “The ties that bind,”
which is an episode where this character
that we know and love started going crazy,
I intentionally mapped out
the whole episode where every act,
the music got a little bit faster
and the key dropped.
So that, you know, to put this sort
of in really easy terms—
so, like in the beginning
of the episode we’re here
♪ [playing note on piano]
and then in the second act,
♪ [playing piano]
you know, just down and down and down.
And you don’t notice it because
it’s over the course of 44 minutes,
but I think that subconsciously things
like that—
that and the way that the rhythm
is just getting faster and faster,
it does create this feeling that
you’re kind of spiraling out
of control towards something.
So that can be a really powerful tool,
and obviously when you’re thinking
in terms of drums
and a lot of my music is very percussion
heavy, rhythm is—
you got to have a cool groove.
Member of the audience: Do you have a dream of something you
want to do that you haven’t been able to do?
And if so, what is that?
Bear: Boy, I don’t know.
I got to score a Terminator TV show,
and, yeah, do an 8-bit thing.
I don’t know.
I mean, my dream is keep writing music and
continuing to do what I love, you know.
And the fact that people are
out there listening to it
is wonderful and icing on the cake.
But I mean like the fact that I can keep—
just keep writing music is
my dream, you know, for sure.
Member of the audience: How did you pick the Gayatri Mantra
for the title, and more generally,
how do you come up with these lyrics in all
these different languages?
Bear: Well, it’s interesting
the mantra came from Eddie Olmos.
Eddie played this on the set
so it was something that even
before any composer was hired
was part of the Battlestar Galactica
universe, you know, in an indirect way.
And what was the other question?
It was about—
Member of the audience: Lyrics.
Bear: Oh, lyrics.
Thank you.
Lyrics are interesting.
I didn’t write any lyrics for
the first couple of tunes.
The first time I wrote lyrics for
the show was for an Italian opera scene
in this comedic moment.
And I wrote these lyrics
that were sort of a parody.
I mean, they were like very
operatic, angsty lyrics.
“Woe unto your Cylon heart,
my girlfriend is a toaster,
the spine glows red,” and you know,
blah blah blah.
And it’s clear as day,
I mean it’s in Italian
but it’s like, if you speak Italian,
there’s no dialogue obscuring it.
And at the dub where the producers
heard it for the first time,
they were like, dude,
this music is really beautiful.
What are those lyrics, by the way?
And I was like, oh, I don’t
have them on me – I’m sorry.
[laughter] Can I – I’ll
show them to you tomorrow.
Knowing that we were shipping
that night and—
cause, you know, I didn’t want them
to get cold feet.
And then after I started
approaching the lyrics more seriously.
In season three, I got to write
the tune that was in Armenian,
and comment on things that I was feeling.
And write a song that I wanted to write,
but also that commented on the—
on the events of the episode.
And it was great because I could always
hide in another, you know, language.
And I always get kind of—
people sometimes they ask, dude,
is that outer space language
that they’re singing in?
And I was like, no way.
Like, I go out of my way
to write these lyrics
and to translate them and to
have them sung authentically.
That’s something – that’s a layer that
I think adds a lot of authenticity.
I love the Ewok song.
I’m not dogging on that.
But I think for Battlestar, it
wouldn’t have been appropriate.
Member of the audience: Have you ever been like
doing the music for a project
and you were like “This is
the worst TV show ever.”
Bear: No, generally
I don’t take those on.
If it’s truly the worst TV show ever.
There are plenty of times, though,
when, you know, you’re working on something that
you have to do your best on
whether you believe in it or not.
You know, I mean, that’s part of
your job. You’re a craftsman,
and sometimes I think about it
like sometimes I’m a guy
who gets to, you know,
paint the painting.
Other times, I’m a guy who
comes in to fix your leaky pipe.
And this thing isn’t working,
and you got to fix it.
And the music can make things better
so sometimes it—
you just got to wear different hats
and it depends on the quality
of what you’re working on.
Thankfully on Battlestar,
most of the time, I was the painter
and not the plumber. You know.
Member of the audience: I appreciate your defense of
the Yub Dub song, by the way.
Bear: Totally, dude.
I miss it.
Member of the audience: I like the fact that Battlestar
Galactica got to have a theme.
Bear: Yeah.
Member of the audience: And everyone’s familiar with
television theme songs or whatever.
Is… Are people in your position,
is the industry,
do they have to defend the idea of
having an opening theme now with,
you know, Dick Wolf, with,
you know, two notes
and some of these shows that are
in prime time who don’t get one?
Bear: Can we show
the Human Target main theme?
Let me show you a main theme I just did.
And then I’ll answer that question.
♪ [music playing]
Bear: So there is an example
of not having to fight for the theme.
I mean, clearly the guys that produce
this show
wanted a strong main title theme with
beautiful visuals and a memorable,
melodic theme.
And it is something that,
if the producers don’t want it,
you know, as a composer,
you can’t change their minds.
But I think that is coming back.
Getting to do a theme song like that,
with a full orchestra at my disposal,
and getting to write a melody like that,
is pretty unusual.
And I’d love for it to become more usual,
and I think not coincidentally,
the guy that hired me to do this show
is a big fan of Battlestar,
and that’s one of the reasons I got the
job is he heard what I doing in Battlestar
and wanted to bring that kind
of energy to his show.
So I’d love to be able to
do more of that.
But for a while there it
was a dying art, for sure.
Raya: Can I make a special request?
Bear: What’s that?
Raya: Can you play the Sarah Connor theme?
’Cause it’s one of my favorites?
Bear: I don’t have it.
I only have the Samson and Delilah theme.
Hang on.
Fiancée asks.
♪ [playing the Sarah Connor theme on the piano]
Bear: I miss that show.
Okay.
Any other questions?
Member of the audience: Yeah, actually that’s a good segue.
I was going to ask about
Sarah Connor Chronicles,
and you did that show for two seasons,
which if I’m not mistaken,
which is the second longest run
you’ve had on a show.
Bear: Up there.
So far.
Member of the audience: So far, of course.
I’m curious if you feel like you’ve had
an opportunity on that to have fun
and basically explore themes.
Obviously, you didn’t have
as long as on Battlestar,
but do you feel like you missed
an opportunity to explore those themes
and those story lines more?
Bear: Well, I mean—
I think I can answer your question.
Yeah, I had a very thematic score
on Terminator.
We were in a very similar situation
with Battlestar,
where we were coming from something that
existed already and needed to know—
are we acknowledging or are
we distancing ourselves?
And with Battlestar,
I could do everything
except for what Stu Phillips did
on the old show.
Obviously, with some disclaimer,
I could spend on hour talking about
how wonderful Stu is and how wonderful
it was to bring his theme back.
But it really was a special
occasion in Battlestar.
Terminator was different
because we wanted to—
we wanted to connect directly
to Terminator 2,
and it should feel very much like a sequel.
So the score needed to
kind of help ease that in.
“Yeah, I know it’s Lena Headey but she’s
the same person that Linda Hamilton was.”
This is the spirit of this is
very much coming out of T2.
So I had that as a starting point,
but I was also able to say to
the producers that the Terminator theme,
I felt, from the movies, is excellent
as it is, I think of Schwarzenegger,
I think of those movies.
I don’t even think of the characters,
like the movies themselves have become
such phenomena
that it’s hard to distance
ourselves from them.
So I thought I don’t think there’s
a theme that’s Sarah Connor’s theme.
So can we try writing one?
And they were open to exploring this
new, you know, musical universe.
And I had an electric string quartet
where we were running the quartet
through amplifiers and digital effects,
actually mostly analog effects,
and recorded the group that way.
We had big metallic percussion,
we had car parts,
and brakes and anvils and hammers
and like – I mean, it was a blast.
And that album is worth checking
out for some of those colors alone.
Thematically, I feel like
I was just getting started.
I mean, I would adore to go back.
And there was some talk of
doing a straight-to-DVD movie.
And I think that ultimately, it’s the just
legalities and the business of it.
You know, the rights are tangled up
with a company that went Chapter 11.
And so it may never happen
and that would make me sad,
but I’m really happy that that album
is out there, that show is out there,
and I was able to – going back to
whoever asked me about my dream,
I was able to contribute something
to the Terminator universe.
I’m thrilled with that, you know.
Member of the audience: Thanks.
Bear: Thanks.
Host: One last question?
Okay.
Member of the audience: For those of us who aren’t
familiar with the terminology,
can you talk about what’s involved
in writing a cue
and why is that more difficult than
writing just some music independently?
Bear: Well, it
depends on your perspective.
I don’t think it is more difficult,
personally.
I think that the difference is that
when you’re writing a piece
of music for yourself,
you need to make yourself happy
and express yourself
and figure out what you’re going to say
and how you’re going to say it
and who your audience is and
how you’re going to perform it—
there’s a lot of variables.
And most of the time when – when
you have an idea, it’s wonderful.
“I just have an idea and
it’s going to spill forth,
and the audience will find it,” but a lot
of the times those things are not as easy.
With scoring for picture,
you know how long it’s going to be,
you know the shape,
you know which characters are involved,
you know the emotions you’re probably
going to want to play.
And I found that I’d become very quick
at looking at a scene
and in my mind almost being able
to score it instantly.
I don’t know the themes.
I don’t know the exact rhythms
but it’s like I can see the shape.
I can see the shape that’s it like,
it’s almost like geometric.
It’s gonna start this way and be
purple and kind of dark and brooding
and then a rhythm comes in here
when this guy says something
or when this action happens.
And then a lot of the times,
I’ll just look at a scene
and then I’ll see these kind of blocks,
and now I go, okay,
what are my rhythms?
What are the pitches?
What are the melodies I’m going to use?
These things are – for me,
they’re relatively easy to that basic
idea of what am I going to say?
And when I’m writing music on my own,
which I love to do—
I’m a tough critic, you know.
And that’s self-censorship kicks in.
I got a cool idea.
No, it’s not a cool enough idea.
Screw it.
And the other thing I find useful
about scoring for TV and movies,
you have a deadline.
So your first idea, you
don’t have time to go back.
And you’re not going to write
three drafts and pick the best one.
The thing you sit down to write,
that’s what’s going on the air.
So if it’s not good when you write it,
you tweak it or you get the performer
to change it, or you edit it later,
but it’s – it’s trained me
to become very fast.
And in fact, I think of myself
creatively almost like a—
I think of my creative mind the way I think
a marathon runner thinks about their body
where it’s just like I’m always
training myself,
and I know the days I need to
get more sleep.
I know the days that I can sacrifice sleep.
I know the hours that I write the best.
I know the cues that I should write
in those hours, you know what I mean?
If I didn’t figure all these thing out
and I was like I’m going to write some cues,
it would be difficult.
But I have kind of learned
how to do these things.
And I mean, with Human Target
being a full orchestra now,
I’m generating between 45 minutes and
55 minutes of original music a week.
And in fact, today’s the first day
I haven’t written music since New Year’s.
So – it’s something that
you just rely on the—
the craft and the technique,
and the things you know.
And when you’re doing a song for yourself,
it’s fun but all those parameters are gone.
You could do anything.
I find that slows me down, you know.
Member of the audience: So I’m not trying to
evoke like things you hate—
Bear: Oh, go for it.
Member of the audience: But do you ever watch a program
or a movie or a project and you say
not only could I have done it better
but I wish I had been able to that?
Not necessarily hating
on the person who did it.
Bear: You know it’s difficult.
I mean, when I—
I have found that, again,
going back to that marathon runner mentality,
I can’t – I can’t shut that off.
So when I go—
I’m so used to looking at picture
and just constantly analyzing every facial
tic, every line of dialogue, every cut,
thinking “all right, what can we do?”
“What’s the best way to do this?”
I can’t shut that off when
I watch anything else.
So it’s very difficult for me—
it’s not about thinking that
this score isn’t adequate.
If anything, I just keep thinking
about what else could be done?
And what I would do and I actually
have to make a conscious effort
to shut that part of my brain off
to enjoy something.
And admittedly, that’s
becoming very, very difficult.
And I’ve been working professionally—
I mean, I’ve been working under deadlines
like this for 7 or 8 years now.
And I – it’s almost impossible.
And should I be fortunate enough
to end up like Elmer Bernstein
and do this until I’m 80,
I can’t imagine that’s it’s
going to get any better,
you know, just doing the condition
the same thing everyday.
So it is tough.
It’s harder to enjoy—
it’s harder to enjoy media in general.
Somebody asked me earlier at lunch
what kind of music do you listen to?
I don’t – I love music but I don’t
necessarily listen to it for fun anymore
because I’m always listening to
the mixes that I’ve got to approve
or listening to the cues that
I just wrote trying to figure out
how I’m going to orchestrate them.
So it’s a part of my life that I—
that I’ve got a new side of it.
A quick tangential side story to that and
the way this has sort of changed my life.
When I was growing up, the first pop band
I was into was Oingo Boingo,
huge fan of Oingo Boingo.
Huge fan.
And now, it’s like I think,
well, am I fan of Oingo Boingo?
And I am not because I work with
these guys almost every day.
I’ve – me and my brother have performed
with them doing Oingo Boingo music
on stage in these crazy sold-out
Halloween concerts.
It’s funny, cause I go, well,
no I’m not—
I still love their music, but it’s
like a different relationship that I have.
And then, that’s my relationship
with music and art has changed
because of my involvement in it every day.
So it isn’t something I enjoy.
I’m sure if any of you guys use
another computer program
or look at another search engine or another
phone or something you – you’re like,
can you just enjoy on its own?
Oh, this is awesome.
I mean, you’re probably all thinking,
you know, the stuff you think everyday.
[laughter]
Anyway, it’s – it’s a lot of fun.
It’s – you know, a wonderful dream come
true for me to be able to do this, so.
Bear: On the way, as we’re walking
out, I want to show the “Apocalypse” video.
I think that’s pretty awesome.
Host: So first of all we’re going to have
a table set up later for Bear to—
if you have time?
Bear: Yes, yes.
Host: Sign some things.
Other than that, thank you all for coming,
and thank you to Bear and Raya.
Bear: Thank you, everyone.
[applause]
♪ Oṃ bhūr bhuvaḥ svaḥ
♪ Tat savitur vareṇyaṃ
♪ Bhargo devasya dhīmahi
♪ dhiyo yo naḥ pracodayāt
♪ Oṃ bhūr bhuvaḥ svaḥ
♪ Tat savitur vareṇyaṃ
♪ Bhargo devasya dhīmahi
♪ dhiyo yo naḥ pracodayāt
♪ Oṃ bhūr bhuvaḥ svaḥ
♪ Tat savitur vareṇyaṃ
♪ Bhargo devasya dhīmahi
♪ dhiyo yo naḥ pracodayāt
♪ Oṃ bhūr bhuvaḥ svaḥ
♪ Tat savitur vareṇyaṃ
♪ Bhargo devasya dhīmahi
♪ dhiyo yo naḥ pracodayāt
♪ Oṃ